this is full circle moment wow this
might be the last one thing
that's right
collected some Hardware this time
together I mean how cool is it to share
this moment with the entire cast
I was I have to say that everyone flew
in from all over the world how cool is
that they all made it Murray gave an
amazing speech
and um I mean I mean everyone is here
except
um
Screen Actors
there's one actor that's not oh oh well
uh Federico the piano player is not here
oh Frederico yeah and uh and and the one
with the voice
a lot of you guys are here I heard you
guys celebrating behind this wall how
who's turning up the most tonight after
this win
what'd you think who's getting wild
Haley Lou right Haley Lou I think and
Theo maybe Theo Theo's Heaven I think I
think Theo Haley Lou and maybe Sabrina
too yeah what was it like backstage
because I heard some Hooten and
hollering I mean everyone's pretty
stoked about this huh yeah they were uh
they kind of lost like they kind of lost
it was so cute everyone just went
berserk are you used to this by now
Jennifer no I mean as you can see I
wasn't used to I didn't you know I
couldn't even put a sense together
tonight because I no I mean you just
you're like oh my God you know this
great moment it's a fluke and then I you
know uh yeah this was unexpected did you
realize in the moment that Austin Butler
was helping you up those stairs as well
ah that were right I mean I I I uh that
was crazy
so good and real quick I asked John this
but did you see everyone kind of
dressing up as you in drag all over the
world as Tanya I should say yes
you're everywhere hey thanks yeah iconic
oh well you know it's the magic of White
Lotus I can't I can't take credit it's
Mike White created this amazing thing
and uh and uh I just happened you know
lucky enough we're in it and you he won
tonight
where's this going
um
I don't know
gonna sleep next to it I think put the
my parrot on one shoulder and the SAG
award on the other the pair has a new
toy I think yeah yeah he'll no he won't
like it
thank you thank you oh there's uh
there's a campaign for Pam Anderson to
play Tanya's sister in season three what
do you make of that oh
oh saw Pam's documentary
and I called you know 100 people to
watch it and I swear to God we all have
the same reaction it's
it's amazing if you have you seen it I
have and she's amazing in it she's so
you finally get the store you know you
finally get the real story and um now
she's gonna have this huge comeback like
not that she was what if Jennifer played
Jennifer's sister oh a twin sister is
there a possibility yeah we could see
you back as a different character
Tanya's sister yeah
uh I don't think Mike's gonna allow that
you know what the gays they're behind
you I think they're trying to murder
right
we love you that's why thank you guys
congratulations
[Music]
foreign